Hi, welcome back to this the third
session that we're doing on growth
investing.
In this session, I want to focus on
screening for cheap growth stocks. If
you remember in value investing, we
talked about screening for value stocks,
low PE ratios, low price to book. We're
going to turn that process on its head
here and bring what Ben Graham brought
to value stocks into the growth stock
domain. In fact, you could argue that
this is essentially the Peter Lynch
contribution to investing because he
brought in the rigor of value investing
into growth investing. Growth at a
reasonable price or GARP. So, let's set
the process up as to what kinds of
screens might give you stock growth
stocks that are cheap.
You could screen just for high growth.
And as we'll see very quickly and
dismiss very quickly, buying stocks with
high growth, high earnings growth has
never been a winner. You have to bring
the pricing in and there are two
variants you might look for. One is just
com looking at know a combination of low
P low P ratios and high growth or to
bring them together into one equation.
You divide the price to earnings ratio
by the growth rate to come up with
what's called a PEG ratio. PEG ratio
very simply is the PE ratio divided by
the expected growth rate. So, as an
example, if you have a stock with a PE
ratio of 20 and a growth rate of 10%, 20
divided by 10 is two. The lower the PEG
ratio, the cheaper the company. In
effect, you're looking for a mismatch. A
stock that trades at a at a low multiple
of of earnings and a high growth rate.
Now you can adapt this to enterprise
value multiples where you look at
enterprise value to EBIT and high growth
in operating income. But essentially
you're looking for a combination of high
growth and low pricing. So let's look at
the different screens and let's start
with the most simplistic screen. You're
a growth investor. What do you what
excites you the most? High growth,
right? Especially in earnings. Now
before we get too carried away though,
remember that there are two ways you can
look at earnings growth. One is look
backwards. historical growth and
estimated past growth. And keep in mind
the caveat that growth can be volatile.
Starting points and ending points can
matter. So you can you can very quickly
make your growth look high or low by
picking a starting period that was a
really good one or a really bad one.
There's some mean reversion in earnings
growth and you assume that you know over
time that earnings growth is going to
move towards the average. And in many
ways revenue growth is more predictable
than earnings growth. historical growth,
you can focus on past growth, use
earnings growth, and if you don't trust
earnings growth, look at revenue growth.
But investing is all about the future,
right? You want to invest based on
expected future growth. So, you want to
pick stocks with high expected growth
rates, and that comes with a catch. You
could try to estimate the expected
growth rate for every company, but
that's going to be tough to do if you're
looking at hundreds or even thousands of
companies. But there's a fallback that
people use. analysts project growth for
companies. Maybe you can pick companies
that analysts are projecting high
expected earnings growth for the
company. Neither strategy has worked
very well in the past. Past growth
doesn't work very well because it turns
out that the correlation, you'll see
this in the next page, between past
growth and future growth is pretty low.
And in many ways though the po the point
you might be missing when you pick high
growth companies even if the growth is
right is what if the pricing already
reflects that high growth. You're
getting a great growth company but
you're paying 50 100 150 times earnings
you might not be able to make money.
Speaking of that correlation in this
graph I've looked at the correlation
between growth in one 5year period and
the growth in the next 5year period.
It's a little dated. 19 to 94 growth to
95 to 999. And you can see the
correlation is very low at small cap
firms, higher at large cap firms. I also
looked at two-year historical growth as
a predictor of two-year forward growth.
Again, lower at smaller firms, higher at
larger firms. And one-year growth, last
year's growth and next year's growth,
lower at smaller firms, higher at larger
firms. Put simply, the kinds of firms
where you're most uncertain about future
growth, small companies, historical
growth is not a good predictor of future
growth.
So that screen of just screening for
companies that have high expected growth
without looking at the pricing is almost
certainly not going to work. So you need
to bring pricing into the mix. And there
are two ways you can bring pricing into
the mix. One is you can just do a very
simplistic comparison of the price
earnings ratio to the growth rate and
only buy stocks that trade at a P ratio
less than the growth rate. That sounds
like a madeup strategy, but it's a
strategy that some growth managers have
adopted with some success over the last
few decades. So, as an example, let's
say you have two stocks. One trades at
20 times earnings and the other trades
at 10 times earnings. By itself, the 10
times earnings stock looks cheaper than
the 20 times earning stock, right? But
let's assume the company that trades at
10 times earnings has a growth rate of
5%. And the company that trades at 20
times earnings has a growth rate of 25%.
With this strategy, you'd buy the second
stock because it has a P ratio less than
the growth rate. The advantage of the
strategy, it's extremely simple. There's
no comp, you know, no need to compute
ratios. But as we will see, it has its
own weaknesses that come with it. The
second strategy is to do what I
suggested. look at the PEG ratio, price
earnings divided by the growth rate, and
to try to big pick stocks with low peg
ratios. A Morgan Stanley study from
decades ago seem to suggest that buying
low peg ratio stocks earned higher
returns than buying high peg ratio
stocks. So, let's take a deeper look at
both of these strategies. Let's say you
adopt a strategy of just buying stocks
and the PE ratio is less than the growth
rate. Here's the first problem. In
periods where interest rates are high,
everything is going to look cheap to
you. 1979,
90% of US stocks traded a PE ratio less
than the growth rate, but interest rates
were 10 12%.
In 20 2018, 2019, 2020, less than 10% of
US stocks trade less than the expected
growth rate. But rather than think of
this as a sign of undervalued versus
overvalued stocks, it's a fact that when
interest rates go up, P ratios for all
stocks decrease. And if interest rates
are high enough, everything's going to
look cheap to you. That's the first
problem. The second is when you just
compare PE to the growth rate and you
don't factor in risk, you can see the
potential weakness, right? That high
growth might come with immense amounts
of risk. A stock that looks cheap
because it's being less than the growth
rate might not be cheap after you factor
in risk. Historically, as I said, people
have used this strategy. It's a simple
strategy, but the payoff to it has
become lower and lower, perhaps negative
now because it's so simplistic. What
about PEG ratios? Again, in this graph,
I've looked at just pure raw returns
based on PEG ratio classes. And the
lowest PEG ratio companies have earned
significantly higher returns. This is
over three time periods,
stocks with the highest peg ratios. Now,
you're saying this is good. I'll just go
by low peg ratio stocks. Remember these
are raw returns. I have it adjusted for
risk and as I said risk might be the
wild card here. The lowest peg ratio
stocks might be earning higher returns
but after adjusting for risk who knows.
So let's take risk as the wild card and
see how it plays out in the PEG ratio.
I've taken a hypothetical company here
with two different potential growth
rates 10% and 20%. and computed what the
PEG ratio will be for stocks with betas
ranging from 0.5 half as risky as the
average stock to beta 1.5 one and a half
times as risky. Notice with both growth
rates expected growth rates a peg ratio
decreases as risk increases. So stock
with a bet of 1.5 trades at a peg ratio
close to one. Stock with a beta of 0.5
trades at a peg ratio of 2.7. One is not
cheaper than the other. They just
reflect risk. The same thing applies as
a with a higher growth rate. As you look
across stocks, you should expect to see
if you pick stocks based on low peg
ratios, your portfolio has a lot of very
risky stocks in it that look cheap but
are not really cheap.
In fact, to kind of establish this even
more um precisely, I broke stocks based
on betas in 2025 into five classes from
lowest betas to highest betas and
computed the peg ratios for stocks
within each class. It's a period where
markets overall have gone up. So, the
PEG ratios have all risen as well. The
lowest risk stocks had a PEG ratio of
2.85.
The highest PEG ratio stocks, the
highest risk stocks at a PEG ratio of
2.01. Riskier stocks will look cheaper
on a PEG ratio basis.
There's one more point about PEG ratios
that I want to bring home. When you talk
about P ratios and growth, we know the
relationship. As growth goes up, holding
all its constant, P ratio should go up.
So, we can control for difference in
growth. A high P ratio versus low P
ratio. you to say I'm going to control
for growth. When you get to PEG ratios,
the relationship with growth gets messy.
What I mean by that is initially as you
increase growth in a company, these are
with hypothetical companies, the PEG
ratio decreases.
But there's a point where as the growth
goes up, the PEG ratio starts to go up.
You're saying, so what? Let's say I give
you 10 companies and I give you the PEG
ratios for all 10 companies and the
growth rates for all 10. You're going to
try to control for growth, right? If
growth has a relationship that's always
in one direction, as was the case with
PE and growth, controlling it becomes
easier. Higher growth companies should
trade at higher PE. With PEG ratios,
that control becomes much more difficult
to impose. I'll be honest with you, I do
not like PEG ratios as a multiple. They
have properties that make them difficult
to work with and can lead you down the
wrong path. But if you do decide to go
with PEG ratios, factor in the reality
that just because you've used a PEG
ratio doesn't mean growth has gone away,
that it's been factored in already, or
that risk has been dealt with. Both have
to be brought into the process. But
overall, if you decide that you're going
to adopt a screening approach to find
cheap stocks for you, here are the three
things that will determine whether you
can be successful.
You have to be better at assessing
future growth than most other people
are. If all you're doing is getting
growth rates that analysts are
projecting for companies and plugging
them in, odds are your chances of
success have dropped off. If you can
come up with more finessed estimates of
growth that are better than the analyst
estimates or better than historical
growth rates, you have a better chance
of success.
Might sound like a broken record here,
but the longer your time horizon, the
greater your chance of succeeding with a
passive growth strategy. is screening
for growth companies and there's a
component of market timing here. Think
of why as with IPOs with growth stocks
what you tend to find is when stocks are
doing exceptionally well growth screens
you know there there are periods where
where growth screens work better and if
you can time these these market cycles
where growth screens work better you
might be able to earn a higher return as
well. There's a market timing component
to growth investing that might not be a
factor when you did value screening. So
in summary, can you screen for cheap
growth stocks? Yes. PEG ratios, P less
than growth. Those screens have a
history of working on paper, but you but
the key is to control for the factors
that might be explaining why the PEG
ratios vary across time risk and growth
that have to be brought into the story.
I hope you found this session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.